the first business venture so to speak I
tried were selling sweet to school at
the time I was looking to buy a
Playstation and I wanted to buy it
myself with my own money at that age
people were not allowed to go outside of
school grounds during the school day
it's a lot perfect I've got a captive
customer base
[Music]
[Music]
so my first tip is eat the Frog eat the
Frog means start your day with the
hardest task you have and it means the
rest of your day becomes a lot more
easier and smoother in sixth form you'd
have three periods for example and
there's times where I would sit in the
free period and do financial forecasts
people look over my shoulder and think
I'm insane but you know it's difficult
to explain but I thought actually okay
if I'm prioritizing this now and because
I know I've got a due date for an essay
in two weeks and it's just about
managing that workflow learn it from
real life is my next top tip both my
parents are deaf so my older sister and
I have been caressed and our whole lives
I think we mature a lot earlier as
children because because we had to if I
go all the way back to the start of
doorsteps that starts when I moved house
when I was about 10 or 11 years old
being carers for my my parents we got a
bit more of a hands-on experience
and of the whole property move so I
tried to understand the breakdown of
costs and yeah a big one inevitably was
estate agency fees so a few years later
we learnt about different disruptors and
different industries taxi driving for
uber shopping with Amazon this is where
I thought actually why don't we try and
connect buyers and sellers directly my
next tip is read a biography for me that
was Michael O'Leary's biography about
when he started Ryanair I think good
biography is really really motivating
and it shows you that it's doable and it
shows you that actually the people that
started these insanely successful
businesses or normal people and actually
they've decided to step out of their
comfort zone and take a risk and that's
really inspiring teach yourself new
things is my next top tip I think
without teaching yourself it's difficult
to start a business because you need to
understand every aspect and whether it's
your forte or not and understanding that
means you can test a business cheaply
and for me that was learning floor plans
from scratch photography from scratch
things I I didn't have experience in so
one thing I couldn't learn myself
unfortunately at that point was learning
to drive that's because I was only about
16 or 17 so to get to my first property
I did have to pay my sister's boyfriend
to drive me down to the property in East
Sussex so I could then go and do the
visit
my next tip is listen to your mum
I understood that my mum 95% of the time
is right and she is wiser than yourself
so my mum has been very influential and
what both my parents have they would
never let the disability stand in their
way
seeing that work ethic especially
tracing back to migration for example
and for my dad from Africa into the UK
and it's not easy and they've actually
managed to get our family to stage where
we are now or I'm actually able to take
a risk in my own life and because I've I
know I've got this stable family
background to be honest the success and
the money hasn't made a difference to my
life I do still live at home still
living my parents I still go to the same
type of place that I used to I still
don't have a car it's difficult to
actually take a step back and look at
the progress you made because I'm always
kind of moving the goalposts further
away so the at the moment we're a
start-up were in the midst of growing
it's really really exciting stages I
think we've got so much more to give
you